in this video you're going to learn how
to solve trigonometric equations and
specifically we're going to talk about
how to find the general solution so
we're going to go through three examples
see if you can do these on your own and
we'll go through them together the first
one we've got 2 cosine X minus 1 equals
0 so when you're solving these trig
equations is very similar to solving
algebraic equations but you want to get
the trig function by itself on one side
of the equation so what we're gonna do
here is we're gonna isolate this cosine
of X by adding 1 to both sides of the
equation so now we have 2 cosine x
equals 1 we're going to divide both
sides by 2 and so now you can see that
we have cosine of x equals 1/2 so now we
want to do is we want to go to the unit
circle and when I ask ourselves where is
cosine equal to 1/2 well remember on the
unit circle cosine is the x-coordinate
and so let's see where is the
x-coordinate and 1/2 well we can see
it's here as well as here so if I just
draw a little sketch over here just to
illustrate here's our unit circle and
you can see cosine is 1/2 right here at
PI over 3 or 60 degrees and over here at
5 PI over 3 or 300 degrees now notice
these points here if we want to write a
general solution what we have to do is
we have to say X could equal PI over 3
plus if we add 2 pi or multiples of 2 pi
we're going to be going around that unit
circle and we're going to be ending up
in the same spot on the unit circle and
the value of the cosine is still going
to be 1/2 so we're going to say PI over
3 plus 2 pi and and then you can write
where n is an integer meaning like you
can can't be 1/2 or 1/3 you have to be
multiples of 2 pi you know can be
positive or negative you can go either
direction around the unit circle so it
can also be 5 PI over 3 plus 2 pi n
again where n is an integer so this is
our general solution for the answer to
this equation now we're gonna go into a
little bit more challenging one in the
next example so let's dive into that one
next okay number two see if you can do
this one we'd have 4 cosine squared of X
minus 3 equals 0 so again we're trying
to I
isolate that trig function by itself on
one side of the equation so we're going
to add 3 to both sides so we get 4
cosine squared X is equal to 3 we're
going to divide both sides by 4 and now
we have cosine squared x equals 3/4 but
we're going to want to do is take the
square root of both sides to get the
cosine by itself and when we do that
when you take the square root of both
sides you get two answers positive or
negative square root of 3 we're going to
leave a square root of 3 square root of
4 is equal to 2 so now what we're doing
is we're saying cosine of what angle
equals positive root 3 over 2 or
negative root 3 over 2 and remember the
cosine is the x-coordinate on the unit
circle so you can see it's going to be
positive 3 over 2 here and here negative
root 3 over 2 here and here so if I just
draw a sketch just to kind of illustrate
here you can see we're at these 30
degree angles these PI over 6 degree
reference angles so you can see it's
actually going to be PI over 6 in each
of these quadrants first second third
and fourth but what I want you to notice
is that see how over here at PI over six
and seven PI over 6 see how they're like
diametrically opposed it's like a
diameter like across from each other and
same thing over here with 5 PI over 6
and 11 PI over 6 these ones are
diagonally across from each other
diametrically opposed so when we write
our general solution we can group those
together to make it a little bit more
compact of an answer so we have x equals
PI over 6 plus because we're going
halfway around the circle here that
represents a 180 degrees or PI radians
so we're going to say plus PI n where n
is an integer and also we're going to
take this one here 5 PI over 6 5 PI over
6 plus PI and we're and as an integer it
can't be a half a third etc so we were
able to group these together to make it
a little bit more compact this would be
our general solution if it just said you
know find all the solutions between 0 to
2 pi ok like this then you would just
say PI over 6 5 PI over 6 7 PI over 6
and 11 PI over 6 but what we're focusing
on here is writing a general solution ok
number three we have a little bit more
challenging one we have cosine X minus
secant of x equals zero how we solve
that one
and by the way if you like the way that
I'm explaining these concepts and you
want to go deeper into algebra to
definitely check out my algebra 2 video
course for sale that goes into all these
different concepts plus more covering
algebra 2 topics but let's jump into
this one here what we're going to do is
we're going to change the secant of X
into 1 over cosine of X because remember
secant is a reciprocal of cosine right
and so now what we're going to do is
we're gonna clear this denominator here
by multiplying through by the cosine of
X so I'm going to distribute that cosine
of X to the left and right sides of the
equation keeping it balanced right so
this is going to give us cosine squared
of X minus 1 okay because here these are
cancelling numerator and denominator and
0 times anything of course is 0 so now
I'm going to add 1 to both sides of the
equation so this gives us 1 + cosine
squared X and if we take the square root
now of both sides to get the cosine by
itself we get plus or minus 1 because
remember when we take this credible
sides we get those two answers positive
or negative so now we go to the unit
circle remember cosine is the
x-coordinate on the unit circle and we
say well where is the x-coordinate 1 or
negative 1 so it's gonna be 1 here and
it's going to be negative 1 here and
those are the only two locations so just
to draw a quick sketch it's going to be
here and here and again notice that
they're across from each other like a
diet diag and all diameter has what I'm
trying to say there so what we have is
we actually have 0 plus we keep adding
PI to get to this point and another PI
to get to this point etc so if we keep
going halfway around that circle right
on up at one of these points where
cosine is positive or negative 1 so you
can see that x equals 0 plus pi + or
since 0 is really nothing we could just
say x equals PI n where n is an integer
and this would be our general solution
if you want to see more examples follow
me over to that video right there where
I show you how to solve even more
trigonometric functions